hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay
you may notice something's different
about me look if you 10 bucks if you can
point it out I'm not gonna say it
something changed hmm no no all right
fine if you couldn't get it I'm not
wearing my glasses I got confidence
today but also you guys have told me
that there is something over here that I
missed yeah something that I missed
about a computer and a button and a fuse
box in here in this area that I need to
fear the Frick and frack out that's not
it
wasn't this one was it no kliklak lino
well but this one nothing in here click
lick lick lick lick lick lick all right
it was something up not in this area
through here they're here no it wasn't
it was it in here oil excuse me mm-hmm
first recording in the morning my video
isn't quite warmed up yet I didn't get
to sing in the shower today
so obviously okay it's down here I think
we jump aw epic catch and then here I
fallen get her
aah we okay it was through here right
earth this way it was the computer
thingamabob err in this way I went the
wrong way something about it climb up on
a box to a fuse do something ah
oh really I can't see anything
chair where's that you're that the chair
Oh
I can't believe it no I can't answer my
phone oh yeah I forgot about that I need
to call her back
anyway all right fine
gah can't believe it all Riley's my love
oh man
I can't believe I missed that how could
I miss that bra because I didn't have
eyes shut up I don't even care Daud Daud
Daud I'm so scared not shut up whispers
shut up whispers and here we go here we
go into the tomb I'm guessing and this
is where I'll find something for the
power generator blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah and then blah
blah and then I'll go on my way to blah
blah oh this can't be good it can't be
good
shut up I think on the positive side
[Music]
as new gate is locked should be ah okay
got a key this is the key click click
click alright now I wish I had but I
don't so [ __ ] me right yeah can't see
anything
like
it is darken
it is dark but I am a rock I will not be
fooled by amateur tricks oh boy
can't see nothing sad oil awesome book -
shut up I didn't even care all the
barrels exploded very very crazy
- ik ray I was at a party last night and
someone said that I wasn't allowed to
say cray-cray or that [ __ ] cray come on
what are you they were they talk what
they talked about right I can say that
right right right
rockin way done sound locking up is all
right I think this is just one big
circle of nothing kind of like the other
area will open up no clock
[Music]
I'm gonna go insane just because I'm
wandering around the darkness received
no light nothing to light with my
tinderbox that's one thing this guy uh
that's one thing this guy forgot
in this level design while he was oh no
he didn't he didn't okay I think this is
the same connecting path that I went on
to find the bucket
I believe no wait I'm wrong
Rick I don't know the layout of this
place yet one just I'm just gonna go
crazy I'm standing in darkness
utter darkness you stand in the light
for a bit I'm not fine I'm fine
I can tough it out
all right I'm back at the beginning okay
that was just too big circuit so I found
a bucket what do i do without the bucket
Oh maybe I'd take a bucket of water that
pipe that was on the side I didn't need
to find him ah-ha darkness it's the
darkness of darkness God why can't I see
[ __ ] this is just a big empty room
ahh I should have expected that ah
you're such a dick
alright whatever here can't see what is
that
oh that's the iron bull torture room
apparently oh [ __ ] I can't see [ __ ]
is that oh yeah that's good wait that's
the the cradle the wheel in here nope
see [ __ ] and even if there was something
in here I wouldn't be able to see it
just look at the top because that's what
I missed last time
all there behind there
they're nothing there's nothing in there
it was just a scary oh you bastard ah oh
you [ __ ]
oh oh oh you dick back that wasn't even
you just through that to kill me you
just did that to kill me you son of a
[ __ ]
oh man okay anyway I got the bucket do I
need from them I need a bucket of empty
wooden bucket was there anywhere that I
there was water I think I don't remember
seeing any water
I know those oil but that was before
I don't know
Oh
[Music]
they'll be making noise like that unless
something gonna happen like seriously
don't be [ __ ] with me I know there
are these doors here that aren't open
maybe they are open now maybe they open
once I get through something this story
yeah the story's closed tight so let me
throw something at it I got to throw a
barrel come here on there all right big
ramp all those Barrow right there
that barrel wasn't good enough huh boof
boof shut up I'm coming to rescue you
moaning guy all right let me go I can of
the way Farrell like that man I'm a
tinderbox do I have five they haven't
even been giving me tinderboxes since
the beginning I don't know why well
probably cuz there aren't that many
things to light here that's don't be
making that noise unless like the red
goop is coming after me the darkness the
darkness okay
oh hello found one all right here we go
what's in here
ladder perfect all right Lucy else
I think that's it whoops surgery won't
be you scare out the top weird is like a
cavern with lights in it I guess it is a
tomb this guy is like just diving into
the jump scares now upkeep oh okay
that's cool you can roar all you want
oh you filled the room with goop okay
unlock the gate of the orb room like
that one that's an orb right where did I
even pick that up I don't even remember
okay the Horeb room I guess that must be
one of the other locked doors in here I
do respect this guy's level design but
the fad the past few scares have just
been cheap I mean it's so atmospheric
already you don't need to make cheap
skiers maybe it was that iron gate it
might have been that I'm gonna check
that out first that's where the thing
jumping out at me and killed me because
it's a dick and then here come on oh you
did use it there we go okay
aha look at that bright shiny thing give
me that why would you have your
generator run off this oh okay fine it's
boiling out I need to cool it down a
good thing I got this bucket and where's
the water
yeah where's the water
gimme the water give me the oil aah whoa
aah water it's blue got it anything back
there so dark I can't see
nothing no oil nothing really
and they even realized that they haven't
given me and they've sent me through all
this darkness your brain is really
collapsing what I didn't even do
anything did I get it oh I got it ah
what the hell let me go let me go let me
go let me go let me go let me go dude
stop hitting me let me go let me go
up hitting me I have a lot of [ __ ]
you are you mannequins I have no light
can't see [ __ ] and knocking my vision to
the side dick move
you're gonna kill me just kill me bow to
me around can't see [ __ ]
hope you realize this guy I can't see
[ __ ] [ __ ] you mannequins
what a dick I used to like this mayor
there's mom
now he's a dick big old dick
Wow all that hurt maybe maybe because I
accidentally touched hit me and threw me
into the mannequins right
it's a deck
[ __ ] you die
if I run into a mannequin I won't be
able to know because I can't see [ __ ]
yeah addy oh don't knock me into him
don't I swear guy I will I will Jack
slap you so hard
can't see [ __ ] can't see [ __ ] you can
see nothing because you haven't given me
I'll in forever
Oh No
[ __ ] you I can't see [ __ ]
oh yes that ik okay yeah now I'm damaged
beyond all reason but I got it orb is
the lost power stone and I can power up
the generator well who runs their
technology off of weird artifacts they
find in underground tombs who does that
is it logical what whatever maybe I'm
overreacting
maybe I need to be more sensitive to
this guy's artistic creation I remember
someone said that that would be hard for
a normal gamer to find do I look like a
normal gamer got a nice buddy do you
thought you could get away by giving me
advice but then you throw that in my
face I'm watching you you know who you
are you know
all right anyway um I'm actually out of
time thank you all so much for watching
no it's ridiculous going through all
that but thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye